We have a whole new bunch of
array methods added in ES6. I'm
going to talk about from and of
first. The reason I'm going to
talk about these two together is
because they both are not on the
prototype. What I mean by
that is, if I create my new
array, like const ages =, and
then ages does not have .from,
and it does not have .of. Why?
Because they are not on the
prototype, they are on the array
itself, so there is array.of and
array.from. What do these do?
First thing that they do is that
array.from will take something
that is array-ish and turn it
into a true array. There's
couple situations where we often
need that, and that is when we
are working with DOM elements.
Let's go ahead and select all
the people. const people =
document.querySelector, and we
want to select all the Ps inside
of people. Now let's console.log
people and see what we have.
Good. We have all of these
people here. Those are the three.
But what if I wanted just an
array of the people's names? I
could do const names = people.
map, and it would take in the
person, and it would return
person.textContent. Give that a
save. Now we get this error
people.map is not a function.
Why is that? Let's do a console.
log of people, open that sucker
up. We have a length, but the
prototype is not an array, it's
a NodeList. That's what I
mean. I've been saying a couple
times in this course, where
something is array-ish or array-
like, and that means that it has
a length, which means it's array-
ish, it has some of the methods,
but doesn't have all of the
methods that a regular array
would have. We looked at that a
couple videos ago. What we
need to do in order to make this
map work? We simply would have
to make another variable, so
const people array = we'll just
call it array.from. Notice how I
call it right off of array, and
then you pass it the thing that
is array-like. In this case, it
is a NodeList that has a length,
so it's going to be able to
convert from that to a real one.
When I console.log people array,
we still get that error. Don't
worry about that, it's because
we hadn't switched it out. Open
it up. Hey, look. The prototype
is array now, and you open that
sucker up, and you see
absolutely all the methods that
you're probably used to. You
can call array.from onto it, and
then I will take this people
array and map over that instead,
and now we should have a names
array, which is actually
everyone's name. Similarly,
we can have also done this array.
from. Just wrap our
querySelector right into it, and
then we don't need that second
variable here. We can just map
over the people. I could
have also done this in one
single go, rather than having to
do it in two lines. array.from
takes the second argument, which
is a map function, which allows
us to modify data as we are
creating the array. I'm going
bring this back to a regular
document.querySelector. I'm
going to do on a couple lines so
it's nice and visible, and I'm
going to say const people array =
array.from. Now I am going to
comment out this names array
here, because array.from will
take a second argument, which is
a map function. I'm going to
say person, and from that we are
going to return whatever we want.
Return
Wes.
Console.log people array. Then
you have Wes Wes Wes. Why?
Because it loops over every
single paragraph tag, and then
return to us something. What
is this person here? Let's
console.log it. Each person is
the actual DOM node, so if we
return, instead of returning
obviously just Wes, we're going
to return person.textContent.
That should give us the actual
person's name. There we go.
Look at, now people array = Wes
Kate Snickers. I created that
array in one single go. I don't
need the names array, where I've
mapped it separately, because
array.from will take a second
argument, which is the ability
to map over it. Another use
case is that if we want to
convert the arguments object
into an actual array. I'm going
to comment this stuff on out,
and we're going to create some
function called sumAll. When
we run it, we're going to call
sumAll and pass it a whole bunch
of numbers that all need to be
added up. We just did an example
like this when we looped over it.
However, if you want to use a
reduced one, I am going to show
you how to actually do that.
Inside of this function I'm
going to console.log arguments.
It looks like an array, and that
would be a perfect use case for
reduce. I'm going to take
arguments, and I'm going to
reduce it, which take the
previous and the next, and
return the previous + next. I'm
going to start with 0That should
work, right? Arguments.reduce is
not a function. Why not? If we
console.log arguments, do we see
arguments.reduce? Here's
arguments. Let's look into the
prototype. I don't see .reduce.
Why not? Because this is
arguments. It is not an array,
it's array-ish. All we would
have to do is say const nums =
array.from(arguments), and then
we use that nums one to reduce
on over it, and our sumAll, if
we were going to call this from
console, you see that we got our
numbers added on up for us.
That's pretty common use case
where you actually do want to
convert your arguments object
onto an array. Again, it is
array-ish, because it has a
length, but it doesn't have any
other of methods on it. Next
up, we have array.of. It's
pretty straightforward. Pretty
much how it works is you say
const ages = Array.of, and you
just pass it as many arguments
as you want. That's going to
create an array from every
single that argument you pass it.
That's
it. There is nothing else much
more to array.of. That's one of
those you put in your back
pocket, because you might need
it at some point.